we binged Jenny and Georgia's second
season and then scoured the internet for
any sort of crumb about what's to come
in season three very impressive we've
got a lot to say about that brutal
Cliffhanger the brilliant improv and
George's wedding dress they had to
literally change venues for because it
was so gargantuan there's a scene in
season 2 that was written to directly
parallel a scene from season one Marcus
was taking care of Maxine when she was
drunk sleep on your side come on
thank you so in season two Maxine gets
to take care of Marcus and the actors
had a great time with these scenes not
only because Felix Mallard got to play
drunk but because at least half of that
scene was improv 50 of that was us just
goofing around and being nut balls there
was a ton of improv on this show
especially during those scenes where
everyone was all together particularly
in bro Cody's basement Felix Mallard was
shook over just how good everyone was at
improv and staying in character it's
almost scary that like when we do huge
scenes like that it's like you'd never
know anyone was acting the atmosphere is
just so light-hearted because the cast
hangs out a lot outside of work but that
fun and natural dynamic between them can
occasionally get in the way on set so
take this scene for example that took
more than five takes to get right
colors hurt my eyes Antonia Gentry
struggled with this one because she was
supposed to be mad not cracking up the
entire time I just kept laughing and it
took like five picks before I was like
all right and this was actually a pretty
common problem for the whole cast
laughing was happening pretty much all
the time we'll talk more on those jokes
later though so take a look at what
they're doing between these countless
takes this isn't even the first time
we've seen actors do this Tick Tock
challenge in their downtime before Sarah
weighs glass and Diesel La taraka
couldn't resist giving the tortilla slap
challenge a try honestly diesel kind of
went in on Sarah did you hear that slap
oh we gotta talk about this finale did
you know that they've had it all planned
out since day one they've even put the
dominoes in place to fall for season
three Austin is definitely gonna be
going through it all in the upcoming
season that trauma is heavy what do you
think about Gill being more involved
with the kids the show's Creator Sarah
Lampert said there is potential for a
lot of story in season three because I
think it is clear that while Gill is an
abuser and he is not someone that we
want around our characters that we love
at the same time I do think it is true
that he loves his son they also
purposely left out Cynthia's reaction to
George's arrest because they know people
are definitely going to be seething with
curiosity about it what are you gonna do
do a lot
we're also pretty curious about what's
going on in the prop Department let's
take this classroom scene and pick it
apart for a second do you notice how the
desks are set up like a normal classroom
for the opening moment whose job is it
to silently pull the desks out of the
way for that close-up and how does one
apply for that position feel free to
answer that in the comments thanks
besides slapping each other with
tortillas we've noticed a theme that
performers love to sing and dance behind
the scenes even masked up for covid you
can't hold back the footwork The Good
Vibes don't just stop there though
[Music]
[Applause]
and here's a little throwback with some
TLC dance choreography in there so there
was a ton of singing and dancing behind
the scenes which brings us to another
important topic sing sing the real
question we had was is it an actual
musical the answer is no but we did find
out that it was based on Chicago
apparently Sarah Way's glass was already
prepared for her lead role in the show's
musical as she unabashedly admits on
Instagram that she usually performs Cell
Block Tango alone in her bedroom who
else was blown away when they saw
George's wedding dress the thought by
behind the blue hue of it was because
after more than one marriage Georgia
would never wear a white dress again
there had to be a particular look in
mind when costume designer Julia patkos
put this dress on her can you guess what
it was
[Music]
the look was based on Cinderella's ball
gown the title of the episode I'm not
Cinderella we definitely don't recall
Cinderella getting arrested in front of
the entire town so what are your season
3 theories let us know in the comments
alright so we're not quite done with
this dress this thing actually caused a
lot of difficulty when it came to
shooting the wedding scene for one Julia
patko says it took over 150 hours to
make it took up the entire fitting room
and four people had to hold it to move
it and they also had to change the
location of the wedding because of that
they had to move to a larger space with
an aisle that could accommodate address
that size we had a full crane shot just
to capture the dress and of course
Georgia needed a costume change for the
reception not just because we couldn't
fit the cameras around the other dress
when she was dancing but also because no
way would Georgia have only one wedding
dress and how about that shootout we're
talking about the scene where Austin
continues his Trek into childhood trauma
and that scene not too funny in the show
but behind the scenes was pretty
hilarious it was like a lot of weird ad
living
you wait there honestly we're happy to
hear the tension was pretty thin he was
approaching too fast and I don't know
the tension in this one though super
thick even behind the scenes don't do
that don't pretend like you're doing
this for me because because I don't want
this Antonia Gentry and Felix Mallard
had a tough time with this one
especially due to the fact that Felix
wouldn't speak to Antonia before they
did the scene considering that the two
are really good friends outside of work
this was not an easy day it was a real
mean to me the whole day will you speak
to me and and it made me sad oh we're on
a roll right now with these tense
moments so let's just talk about Georgia
sneaking off to tuck Tom in for well
ever this was an intense scene for
Brienne Howley to film seeing Jordan
like that decision yeah it was like
brutal imagine shooting at you guys but
as always something hilarious seems to
come out of itself when I was in the
hospital my dad did this scene with me
all right you know those Hannah Montana
transition vocals
I'm Hannah Montana
me Miley yeah the cast does those in
between takes diesel started it and it
took off with everyone else standing on
the side like oh whoa yeah
so apparently it wasn't a lot of
downtime but nonetheless that's what
Antonia and Brienne would get into when
they had some I would order McDonald's
like every day remover eight it was also
super cold at the time so they were like
constantly huddled around the heaters I
mean I don't think we were very healthy
so considering how 10 cent dramatic this
show can be I guess a desire to do bad
things we were excited to find out how
much fun this cast had behind the scenes
it's like there's just like an energy
and we just can't stop making each other
laugh it's also kind of impressive just
how much improv and ad-libbing happen in
scenes we would never even know about so
what was your favorite behind the scenes
moment